é quando foi convidado para falar
athletics olhei para o leitor a dor é em
nomes como antonio câmera e fui um
gringo ansioso quanto é eu estar à
altura das expectativas não foi então
que o é que o andré disse que o vieira
pessoas que moravam em um matagal e foi
suficiente para convencer
quanto ao contrário aqui desde criança
eu ligo o computador é consegue spectrum
30 minutos ela era um jogo a maior parte
das vezes jogo em que gravava não vejo
nenhum doente e foi desde essa altura é
e mesmo não seria trabalhar nesta área
após a minha formação acadêmica como
engenheiro informático para trabalhar
como o anauê software e depois optei por
trabalhar no desenvolvimento miguel
jorge e quase ao fim da oficina algum
tempo seria lançado no meu próprio no
próprio negócio é só com a fundadora
louça é na lousa e investigamos
desenvolvemos soluções web
trabalhamos também muito para internet
das coisas
recentemente participamos é num concurso
promovido pela nasa na holanda é a idéia
era desenvolver um protótipo que os
assassinatos do espaço e nesse tempo que
desenvolverá em 36 horas desenvolver uma
aplicação é desenvolver uma aplicação
ele lamentava aonde nós localizada a
estação é é especial no bahia e podíamos
comunicar com o gestor novas câmeras e
região através do twitter
é esse protótipo volume de prémios na
função mais inovadora é o salva a minha
vida como já deve ter prazo é realmente
a tecnologia foi uma vai falar da
tecnologia mas não é no meu nome eu no
meu passado no início de 2014 é nos
estados unidos da américa é o acesso à
internet através de dispositivos móveis
ultrapassou o o acesso a partir dos pcs
tanto isso pela primeira vez é essencial
se em cima das palavras em 2014 era self
é uma das palavras mais faladas cá em
portugal
em 2015 será eu sou eu chamar tudo jesse
martin smartphones martins smart
technologies smart forma e tetra é
aquilo pra nós é mais comum o movimento
no dia a dia é o smartphone é uma
corrida para alguns é uma preocupação é
o smartphone aquilo para o qual nós
olhamos é assim que cuidamos e última
coisa para a qual nós olhamos é quando
nós vamos tentar escrever por movimento
que sou solteira cantando a informação
disponível no nosso bolso esse é o nosso
nosso trabalho é maior
deve ser muito mais eficaz no nosso
trabalho é eliminar perfeitamente às
novas tecnologias
no entanto ainda algum distanciamento
das pessoas algumas pessoas pelo menos
em relação à tecnologia é se a uma
aplicação no trabalho não funciona vamos
chamar o informático o informático é não
está presente não está preparado para um
formato que o problema é sempre um
informático então a combater estes
distanciamento vamos abraçar a
tecnologia é a forma mais umbilical e
não digo que devemos usar ainda mais o
facebook ou ou julgar mais na
playstation no ipad league cinco devemos
perceber mais intrinsecamente a
tecnologia é ea forma como estamos
preparados para os empregos do futuro é
necessário parar mas já falei duas vezes
nos empregos do futuro é de um curso é
suficiente
hoje já não é exceção necessária skills
isso que o espaço na maior parte das
vezes por é forçosamente temas como
tendências tecnológicas anos vou falar
word o excel em maio é tetra e se as
trilha é a 15 anos atrás
abordando a temática de outra forma e
olhando para este gráfico nós vemos que
especificamente néné programação para
smart produtos né na área da internet
das coisas em 2014 falava cerca de 300
mil programas nesta área a professora
que para 2020
estamos a falar de cerca de 4.5 milhões
de
e programadores é nesta área ou seja uma
creche em cerca de 1.500 por cento
aí o que são estes produtos inteligentes
que fazem o que os fazem diferente para
com os os tradicionais para com os
produtos ditos tradicionais produzem
grandes volumes de dados
e esse grande volume de dados precisam
ser armazenados empregados representados
e analisados eram usados por quem por
nós todos nós que trabalhamos no dia a
dia vamos ter que analisar estes dados
com alguns nós já fazemos mas também
estamos muito mais debilitados é nós
próprios que nós sabemos do nosso
negócio alterar os mecanismos é saber
como aplicar o nosso conhecimento a
melhor representação desses dados
por isso é novo não você só os
programadores a fazer isso deve ser
também todos nós é então não vejo uma
programação é estritamente com uma
carreira tempo inteiro
devemos todos nós estará apto a lidar
com os novos desafios caso contrário o
nosso próprio emprego é poderá estará em
risco a seleção natural é dura mas ela é
mundial acontece esta frase é dos times
jobs é diz que todos neste país devem
aprender a programar programará ensino
já pensado
ora eu fico extremamente sensibilizá lo
e com o facto de não se preocupar tanto
com o nosso país
obviamente não estava falando estados
unidos da américa mas isto é é pra todo
mundo é pelo menos da forma que eu então
a gente analisa
mas brincadeiras à parte eu estava muito
muito certo é a minha missão aqui hoje
motivarmos é é programar a aprender é
pôr as mãos na massa e começar do zero
ou programar quem não programar que
alguém com certeza que virão aqui alguns
programadores que programa nessas ao
pronto já não parti do zero já que já
haja missão cumprida é tanto não só pela
componente das profissões do futuro como
falei mas programar e os programadores e
que saberão disso é obrigado de explorar
a lógica é bastante é algo que só quem
começa a programar e que serve essa
diferença e lógica
é um raciocínio mais bem estruturado até
um dos benefícios também não tem
programa aí é uma questão de tempo até
que também é programação faça parte da
educação dos mais novos
a loja matemática português e etc
nesta nossa imagem dos caras tanque
bastante conhecidas da tecnologia e não
só é vemos o bill gates fundador da
microsoft mark zuckerberg do facebook o
director se do twitter e todos os réus é
é esse e todos os que estão nesta esta
nesta imagem é ela não é que todos nós
começamos de alguma forma programar
porque programar eheheheh permite-nos
ter um pensamento está mais eficiente é
é preciso formar mais gente nós e também
compromete os nossos filhos
e lá está os nossos filhos devem começar
a programar desde muito desde muito
novos para ele que vemos aqui é o harry
pai é é um pequeno computador qualquer
um pode adquirir cerca de 30 euros
é a imensa programa de hoje a fazer em
protótipos com com harry pai por sua vez
posteriormente dão azo a um produto
comercial
há também várias iniciativas é crianças
que são introduzidas a programação
usando o próprio harry pai e há já
algumas escolas um pouco por todo o
mundo é questão é ensinar os mais
pequenos já programados e 1 também é
temos aqui o psicólogo do programa mais
simples no mundo real ou não é mais do
que o primeiro com as palavras não é
foi este o primeiro programa já muitos
anos atrás
é esse também o primeiro passo que hoje
é incentivar e começar a construir
alguma forma é programada a mas acima de
tudo a pé ou no futuro é no futuro
próximo essas crianças a partir do
quinto ano de escolaridade tenham
possibilidade de ter uma disciplina ao
lado da matemática da settra é onde
aprendam é programar mesmo muito nosso
muito obrigado
foi por exemplo